washington is a place on edge shops and
businesses remain
boarded up the cumulative effect of a
pandemic
black lives matter protests and now the
violence on the hill
which continues to send the jitters down
the spine
of this city the focus remains though on
donald trump's role in
instigating this carnage in america's
seat of democracy
democrats still weighing up whether to
impeach
but it's looking increasingly likely in
this moment
when the president spurred on an attack
a physical attack on the united states
congress in the capital
there has to be a consequence or the
constitution ceases to have any real
meaning
and an indication of just how serious
this is
it's no longer simply a partisan matter
senior republicans have also been
repulsed
openly denouncing trump's behavior and
his fitness for office
well i think the best way for our
country chuck is for the president to
resign
and go away as soon as possible to many
the president
hasn't just broken democratic norms he's
trampled on them
and smashed them into pieces
president trump hasn't left the white
house since the violence
he's accused of inciting erupted at the
capitol building
he appears increasingly isolated but
unrepentant these are dark days to mark
the end of a presidency which has tested
the limits
and the boundaries of the american
constitution
trump is expected to surface from his
bunker on tuesday
he's scheduled to come here to texas to
review progress on the border wall with
mexico
it was a key priority for his presidency
it is unlikely to shift the narrative
for many americans
this will be his legacy since 9 11
nothing has disturbed the american
psyche so much
with the insurrection being compared to
one of the most monstrous days
ever recorded in history i grew up in
austria
i'm very aware of crystal nacht or the
night of broken glass
it was a night of rampage against the
jews carried out in 1938
at the nazi equivalent of the proud boys
wednesday was the day of broken glass
right here in the united states
but donald trump's mythomania lives on
supporters in kentucky still protesting
the election was stolen
the universe of alternative facts the
45th president has constructed
still mobilizing his base joe biden's
inauguration
is just days away but it feels like it
will need more than a new
president to give america a fresh start
and the chance to heal the appalling
divisions that are pulling
this nation apart alex rossi sky news
washington